I know no contracts have been signed
with the enterprises.
The directors have told me,
so why are you fooling around
it will be ready
during this quarter
based on the funds available
under the budget.
I want all of this
to be done within a month.
What quarter are you talking about?
Do you not understand the circumstances
we are in?
Please complete this work within a month.
Agreed?
We will try to do our best.
No. Do not try to do your best.
Please get it done in a month.
No later.
I think what it's really designed to do,
honestly, is to deflect himself
from any criticism
for the handling of this war
a lot of the issues
that have kind of plagued
the Russian military.
They're a product of the incompetence
and corruption
that have really flourished under
Vladimir Putin's leadership.